[Music]
coming off of a heavy weather week here
in las vegas it's important to talk
about what to do if you get in a car
accident especially in the rain and
thanks to our sponsors for this next
segment eric palacios and associates we
have some helpful tips to keep in mind
eric thank you so much for joining us
today a lot to talk about we saw a
pretty intense weather day here in las
vegas this week which usually means we
see a lot of car accidents let's talk a
little bit about why we do see so many
accidents when it rains here in las
vegas
we did uh see a lot of accidents in the
past few days with rain and it's based
on on two factors one uh we get about
one-fifth of what the rest of the
country gets on average for
rainfall
and rain days uh in las vegas we average
about 20 days of rain per year
and that's not a lot so with that uh
comes more oil and debris that stays on
the roads for a longer period of time uh
so normally this is washed away by rain
so since we sometimes go months without
a rainstorm when it does rain the roads
are very slick and two because we don't
see much rain uh us as drivers sometimes
don't
change our driving habits when we are
driving in the rain so we will drive at
the same speed we won't slow down a bit
we won't add more room between the car
in front of us and our own car
so when there is a need to brake quickly
or to change our speed it leads to
accidents
and if we do get in a car accident what
tips or suggestions do you have as far
as what to do next
well even uh more importantly on days of
rain be careful when you get out of the
car a lot of times you'll see a chain
reaction accident because of the
conditions because it's harder to see
and the last thing you want to do is
step out of your car and then uh get hit
and be injured uh even worse so it's
important to take a breath make sure
that it's safe to get out of the vehicle
uh and then once you are safe then call
the police and they can come and help
you and investigate the accident
and then as we deal with the aftermath
of an accident i think a really big
question that we all have is should we
be the ones dealing directly with the
insurance companies
a lot of people think that it's a good
idea to talk to the insurance company on
your own but be aware that especially
the other drivers insurance company
their goal is to
not pay you or to pay you as little as
possible if it's their driver's fault
so they always record the conversations
they have to let you know they're
recording it but they still do and
they're trained to ask you questions
that will
elicit responses
that will later harm your case so it's
important if you're injured in an
accident to let an attorney handle these
conversations for you that way we can
protect your rights
and just real quick this is a little
confusing too to know when you're
supposed to call
versus 911 if you're in any sort of
trouble or accident
that's a great question uh 9-1-1 should
be only if you're injured in the
accident and
you need an ambulance
if you're not seriously injured if
you're okay but you still need an
officer to come and write a report and
investigate the accident then you can
call 3-1-1 it takes a little bit longer
but at least you're not clogging up the
emergency lines for something that's not
truly an emergency
well eric thank you so much for breaking
this all down for us we hope everyone
stays safe out there but just really
important to keep in mind if you're
driving especially in the rain so thank
you eric
thank you for having me
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
give them a call at 702-444-7777